if I go pitch now do you know they're
like who's this character and you're
like that's the friend they're like are
they Indian or something and you're like
I mean I don't know sure should they be
and they're like it would be better
um and you're like okay and if it feels
like it's so forced yeah yeah in in the
into these conversations yeah but that's
but that's not even new I mean there is
the thing about it like we watch what
was it I think you got mail I think it's
you got mail all right okay so uh that's
the Tom Hanks yeah Tom Hanks and uh Meg
Ryan movie and he's like sort of like
the uh uh the vice president of like
Barnes and Noble or something like that
but his best friend is Dave Chappelle
yeah yeah okay where's the world where
the vice president of Barnes and Noble's
best friend is Dave Chappelle you know
uh I'm actually quite known for writing
my black characters all right but I'm
not gonna you know but it's like well no
if I wanted him to be black I would have
made him black if I wanted him to be
Mexican I would have made the character
Mexican